besançon lieu dit les fous note
nous sommes à quelques centaines de
mètres seulement du palais granvelle ici
vivent une trentaine de familles qui ont
une moyenne de neuf enfants
où
quelle est l'origine de ce monde ont bel
et bien l'association d'accueil aux
travailleurs algériens qui est devenu
depuis l'association d'accueil de
travailleurs migrants pour loger des
familles venant de l'aurès les familles
algériennes avaient avec l'aide de la
ville et du ministre est compétent
établissez si barak a qui dans l'idée
des promoteurs et devaient être des
logements de transit
ça n'a pas pu fonctionner de façon
correcte les logements étaient petits
les bras qui était petit on les a
d'abord a grandi dans un premier temps
et puis les familles algériennes n'est
ce pas se sont multipliées on a fait
venir le cousin la belle soeur avec des
enfants ça aboutit n'est ce pas en
réalité à une sorte de bidonville par
les appentis de toutes sortes en taule
en planches que vous avez pu voir
ça fait longtemps vous habite au fus
note
c'est pourquoi vous êtes venu habiter
ici mais on habitait avec et janvier et
vous avez combien d'enfants
j'en ai 16 jeunes et encore 14 avec moi
ça fait longtemps vous êtes ici madame
oui sinon non seulement et on est
quatorze enfants il y avait combien de
pièces - deux géants les années quatre
vingt quatre heures en plus de ne pas
toujours pas de surface rien et où par
aucune commodité c'est même pas la
lumière
ayant quelques sorties jouer dans cette
première tentative il était nécessaire
d'envisager de raser les fous note est
de faire une véritable cité de transit
andul qu' il y as chez les algériens une
volonté de promotion et la dénomination
des fous notes étaient dix ans devenu
péjorative et ils en ressentent
eux-mêmes la marque sur ce nom de
l'escale est un débouché vers l'avenir
vers l'espérance qui leur sourit tout à
fait
il ya une majorité d'algériens mais il
ya également des gitans pour la plupart
ferrailleurs et quelques familles
métropolitaine n'est ce pas inadapté
alors les jeunes algériens à votre avis
les accepterons aisément de les habiter
dans ces logements dur oui ils sont
d'une façon générale extrêmement
satisfaits
je suis content d'aller dans les
nouveaux logements
c'est pourquoi pour dans le mois
prochain au monsieur qu'est ce que ça
vous fait vous déménagez vous habitiez
une belle caravane à faire valoir et
après vous allez donc aller dans les
nouveaux logements
non non et vous êtes contents de la ba
oui j'aime plaît s'il vous plaît c'est
vous qui avait demandé à y aller oui on
vous a obligé c'est vous qui l'a jamais
demandé vous êtes contente de pouvoir
bientôt déménagement du parce que s'il
faut passer un hiver comme l'an passé
c'est pas la peine j'en ai encore un
petit à 8 mois alors les gitans leur
problème est différent
1 le gitan est un indépendant et il as
le problème de la ferraille il
il aime être seul à voir si les ans tout
autour de son logement
et je dois dire que pour les gitans le
problème des gens nous donnent plus de
soucis que votre mari quelle profession
récupérateur est pour vous le loyer sera
payé c'est normal nous venions un
logement de combien tu as alors pour 6,6
et un appartement mais c'est vraiment
confortable êtes content d'aller dans le
nouveau logement d'abord et s'il vous
plaît les familles que nous allons loger
sont des familles nombreuses puisque
comporte de six à quatorze enfants par
le mécanisme de l'allocation logement la
part qui reviendra à chaque famille se
situera entre 100 et 130 francs par mois
ce qui est tout à fait action de 9,6
pour des f 6
une nouvelle vie va commencer pour ces
familles et il faudra savoir gré au
bureau d'aidé sociale de besançon
d'avoir mené à bien cette difficile
opération escale les 300 personnes des
fous note s'installeront dès la fin de
l'année dans leur nouveau logement et au
printemps prochain
tout le monde devra être relogée